en parle en direct avec nous sur rt
france françois grosdidier maire de metz
et président de metz métropole bonjour
bienvenue sur rt france
alors votre ville est concerné par ce
couvre-feu à 18h votre première action
oui le préfet m'a confirmé que la
moselle l'était aussi je regrette
profondément cette décision et j'avais
dit au préfet que qu'il ne fallait pas
la prendre parce que les bénéfices
seraient nulles et les inconvénients ça
énorme les inconvénients ça va être de
compliquer considérablement la vie des
citoyens qui eux n'auront pas le temps
de quitter leur lieu de travail pour se
rendre à leur domicile et encore moins
de faire quelques courses entre les deux
alors qu'ils en ont besoin
sur l'organisation de leur famille les
commerçants même de produits non
alimentaires on a encore plus besoin que
les autres pour liquider leur stock
nous avons cent mille mosellan qui
franchissent tous les jours la frontière
du luxembourg pour aller travailler et
pour revenir qu'ils n'y arriveront pas
et pourquoi j'y suis hostile parce que
ça n'apportera rien c'est vraiment nous
devons appuyer sur le frein la seule
solution qui marche c'est le confinement
le vrai comme en mars avril celui qui
fait que tous les salariés qui ne sont
pas absolument indispensable mais aussi
des collégiens les dessins des étudiants
reste à la maison et ça ça fonctionne le
reste fonctionne très peu j'étais
partisan du couvre-feu je l'avais
demandé parce que ça marche aux heures
avancées de la nuit partir de 22 heures
quand il ya du relâchement dans les
bistrots dans l'espace public
mais entre 18h et 20h au moment où les
gens et bien sont masquées pour se
rendre éventuellement dans des magasins
cela n'a aucun sens
l'épidémie se propage dans la sphère
privée le gouvernement n'a pas de moyens
pour agir dans la sphère privée
alors ils se donnent bonne conscience en
prenant d'autres décisions mais qui sont
autant de levier inopérant alors vous
parlez de confinement c'est ce que les
français redoutent que les durcissements
des restrictions à crescendo pour
l'instant on parle de couvre-feu avancé
puis peut-être dans quelques semaines un
nouveau confinement
à ce rythme là les commerçants vont-ils
survivre
non non qu'est ce qu'il faut faire
quand on arrive vraiment à saturation
des urgences c'était le cas à nancy mais
pas encore à metz
à ce moment là il faut re confinés comme
je les dis brutalement comme en mars
avril
c'est le seul moyen de décélérer
fortement et de dégager les urgences
mais la seule sortie possible c'est la
vaccination alors c'est la
responsabilisation maximum dans la
sphère privée
on a vu les limites de l'exercice au
moment du réveillon mais c'est la
vaccination il n'y a que la vaccination
massive qui va nous permettre de faire
reculer de faire disparaître cette
épidémie est à nous tous de reprendre
une vie normale
alors on l'a vu à cette campagne de
vaccination est beaucoup critiqué en
tout cas par les détracteurs du
gouvernement elle serait trop lentes on
l'avion en quelques jours en allemagne à
vacciner des milliers de personnes quand
la france on a vacciné un peu plus de
sens est-ce que vous aussi vous juger
cette campagne vaccinale française trop
longtemps oui je vous le confirme un
département la moselle et voisins de
l'allemagne on voit comment ça
fonctionne
la santé est à la main des länder c'est
à dire des régions ça fonctionne il y a
deux fois moins d'administratifs par
rapport au nombre de soignants par
rapport à la france
la même part de la richesse j'ai
consacré à la santé il ya trois fois
plus de lits d'urgence devrait quand
même s'en inspirer un peu ils sont plus
régionaliser ils sont beaucoup plus du
s'adapte beaucoup plus facilement
ils sont plus souples ils sont que speed
et ils ont été plus rapides sur les
masses et le sont beaucoup plus sur la
vaccination alors il faut qu'on arrête
de disserter sur ceux qui ne veulent pas
être vaccinés d'un aura toujours un
certain nombre il faut que tous ceux qui
souhaitent être vaccinés puisse les très
rapidement et je suis sûr que d'ailleurs
beaucoup de réticences suivons eniac
ainsi que nous pourrons sortir de
l'épidémie et puis aborder 2021 comme il
le faut c'est à dire embrasser l'avenir
avoir des projets quoi aller de l'avant
vous êtes donc optimiste en ce 1er
janvier à 2021 optimiste à condition que
nous ayons très rapidement les vaccins
je suis inquiet devant la lenteur dans
mon département qui est si toucher aux
points d'avancé le couvre-feu eh bien
nous n'auront que quelques dizaines de
vaccins disponibles à partir de lundi
quoi on va faire quelques ehpad tout ça
et beaucoup de faux noms ils vont
beaucoup plus vite de l'autre côté de la
frontière
je n'arrive pas à comprendre pourquoi
l'état français n'est pas aussi
performant que les autres pays européens
où d'autres pays du monde
françois grosdidier merci d'avoir
répondu à nos questions je rappelle que
vous êtes maire de metz et président de
metz métropole merci d'avoir été en
direct avec nous sur la défense